[Music]
hi I'm grace ann baker product manager
for a persistent disk and before we saw
it off just want to thank you all for
coming first coming to next I know
you've taken a long time to come here
for three days and most importantly
thank you for coming to hear about
persistent disk and I'm Antone suckin
off I'm a part of the system disk
engineering team and we also have
several other engineers from persistent
disk here who will help to answer
questions so just a brief summary will
talk about the simplicity performance
snapshots talk a bit about precision
disk and G key and some recommended
sessions if you wanted to learn a bit
more about persistent disk or how it's
used as part of as a product on gcp and
then open up for questions generally
speaking if you have a question there's
microphone in the middle of the room try
to keep your questions to the end of the
session however if there's something
that's just not resonating or just
doesn't connect feel free to you know
just raise your hand and we'll try to
get to you well the session is being
recorded so please part of the hygiene
and using the microphone is just so that
you know for later use they'll be able
to capture what the question was and
with that I'll begin so on gcp we
actually have three storage officer
before I go into this how many of you
are gtp users today persistent disk
users so it's about at about sixty
percent of the use of the the room and
so and GCF object store anyone in the
room using to see else okay so let's
goodness you'll have a sense of what the
product is and in which case you know if
you would like deeper information ask
questions we're also going to be around
later on so if you'd like to just give
me your name and we could arrange to
talk offline after so on gcp right now
we have three storage options we have
or optic storage and we actually have
two storage offerings that are both for
block storage available for compute
engine our VM ware based product GCF is
our object storage geo redundant
primarily used for live in archival data
a lot of more streaming were cases for
block storage or four gve we have what's
called local SSD and the way to think
about local SSD is that it is running in
the same machine as your vm or SD
instance it tends to be used for more
clothes that require very ultra high
performance however the one caveat is
that it's referral so if anything should
happen to that p.m. your data is also
gone so the life of your data exists
just in a constructive that instance
persistent disk on the other hand which
is the other storage offering is dis
available for anything them that you're
using as part of GCE it is highly
durable which means that the disk is is
a standalone entity if the vm goes a
ways or comes back or you would like to
use that via that disk of different
beyond you can do that around fairly
high performance and so this is a
product that's targeted at enterprise
applications of any introverted relized
enterprise applications requiring for
virtual lock storage is where you would
use persistent disk so when you're
thinking of performance that snow levels
performance we're talking about with
persistent disk and just as a caveat
this is the product rigor to talk about
today if you're interested there are
lots of sessions focused specifically on
GCF local SSD is being addressed in the
context of compute engine and so if
you're interested in learning more I
suggest some the compute engine sessions
and today we're talking about persistent
disk which you'll hear me refer to a
speedy I do have some sessions listed at
the back of the presentation so if
anyone's interested in some of those
other sessions it's in the presentation
so starting with persistent disk into
skills
I think one of the key things about PCP
in general and specific to GCE and
persistent disk is we really try to keep
it simple for our customers we don't
have a large set of options available
for customers and the idea there is that
rather than customers having to really
think hard about what are their
workloads what are the use cases and
then try to map it to different skills
offering we really try to keep it simple
as to two offerings and you'll see a lot
of things they're just bundled as part
of the base offering or these two
offering these two SKUs will stretch and
fifth different workloads so starting
out with key characteristics PD standard
is really what you would see being used
for more of our general purpose for
clothes thing about there is good enough
performance and when I say good enough
people are almost like resent what is
good enough going up up turns out to be
good enough for the bulk or the large
swath of enterprise applications that
really don't need ultra high performance
that you would see or that's available
with your flash drive so what I'm
talking what performance they're talking
both latency and also I on and so if
you've lot you know your enterprise
database that I really need high
throughput high bandwidth high latency
then definitely PD SSD is most likely
your product the other thing there is
you tend to be less price sensitive for
those types of applications those are
the applications that you would run on
pd SSD for most of your other
applications they do fairly well on pd
standards and and this is just a typical
and i know that in the enterprise it
really isn't any typical application and
i know that you know people say well i
show enterprise apps as pdfs as they
truthfully they they run in either
either of these columns other key points
is so just to give in a sense of how do
we differentiate these two what are the
key characteristics between PD standard
and pd SSD you can see I ops per gig and
here you're seeing a meaningful
difference between the two offerings for
PDF of these got 30 I ops / dig whereas
for standard it's just you know point 75
to read and 1.5 for right for things if
you look at your max I ox you're going
to say for PT standard for reads it's 3k
for rice 15k psst on the other hand it's
40k read I ops and 30k for right I ops
and I'll just pause for a minute here
and comment to that is actually
something new today at next one of the
things we're announcing is the higher I
ops availability for PDF see so if
anyone that is available today for many
of you who said you that you are using
PD if you're using persistent disk SSD
you're getting that performance level
today or you should be and if you're not
please let us know at last point in this
because I know a lot of people are
probably wondering so what's the big
difference according to that goes beyond
the characteristics of the drives of
salt you can see there's a big
significant price difference between
these two offerings okay um so when you
just talking a bit more about what is
Pacific in the key features so I
mentioned earlier that it's persistent
and that's really just comes back to
this construct of the life of your disk
is not tight to the life of your
instance and so however most of the time
to use your persistent disk someone
creates a vm on compute engine and with
that you're also going to create a diff
to go with it anything should happen to
that disk anything shuttle to the
connectivity to the disk the dicks lives
on you should then decide that you're
going to have another application that
needs access to that same data just
create that new instance and connect it
to your desk and you're up and running
we have this idea of how many disks that
you can attach two of the M and we hear
this fairly often and so the number of
this that you can attach to any given
instance is 16 drive for 16 disk
up to and you can have both read write
and read only discs at any given time
you can only have one read/write disk
attached to a vm but the number of reno
late will vary and that's really a for
you to decide decide and here you can
also want another feature of the product
is you can have for those read-only
discs you can have those being read to
from multiple VMs also once again that's
up for you to decide for your different
environment and on the subject of
availability PD is a zonal service and
what that means is that one of the only
you know restrictions around persistent
disk is that it needs to live or it does
live in the same zone as your vm
instance they're highly available and
under the covers one of the things we do
with persistent disk to drive the high
availability is for every right there's
actually three replicas written
customers are of course only charged for
one one of those copies however the way
that we deliver greater availability
customers is this idea of the multiple
rights being done on to the covers and
this here is just intended to show that
the soul construct of if you have
multiple PDS and you happen to have
those instances in different zones the
discs that attach to those instances
will all also exist in those different
zones talk a bit about capacity and the
actual numbers for the systems so the
maximum PD size right now with 64
terabytes you know one of the things
you're very interested in is if anyone
has the need or how big is the need for
large for that number to increase we you
know it's one of those things that we've
been working and doing but you know
priorities changing so I'd love to get a
signal as to how important that is for
both customers we're seeing that you
know 30 20 to 30 terabytes is you know
good enough we do have some larger but
now that's something that would be
interested to know about coming back to
this how many decides to a p.m. if you
recall earlier I mentioned that you can
actually have multiple discs attached to
a vm one of the constraints even though
you can go up to 16 discs the sum of
those 16 discs cannot exceed 60 4
terabytes so you can't have like 1664
terabyte disk attached to a vm and i
think one of the key things here is this
whole construct off do you need to
stripe or not and and this is one of the
things that key differentiator for us is
this idea that you can go up to have
this very large dry and not have to
striper so there's a whole level of
management complexity or management
overhead that you don't even need to
think about as you scale your data set
to these larger numbers and then lastly
these or lastly I think one of the other
things that the team you know stresses
with me is this whole construct is being
able to hot grow your desk so often
sometimes you know you're not sure what
size this to get and you know so you
start small and as your needs grow you
can readily just grow your this size
without having to stop or stop and
restart or do anything on the vm prince
of once again just giving you a lot of
flexibility without any downtime in your
environment on the subject of encryption
and security and this is one of those
features where you know coming back to
the point of trying to keep the product
simple trying not to have you know whole
balance of bells and whistles that
people have to think about about through
their different data sets in their
environment around which the risk
persistent desk and on the platform
[ __ ] all this all of your data is
encrypted and it's just it's always on
one of the core features
we support both by default it's google
generated keys but for instances or
customers where they have their own keys
we also support that so it's fully
integrated with our cloud TMS system and
I think one of the other things on the
subject of security is because Google
runs entirely in the Google Network your
data never leaves the Google Network so
there's no concern about being in the
public internet and so there's this idea
well what about data in flight and so
the question is all it's never leaving
the Google Network and it's encrypted
whilst on the network so it's just a way
of a different way of thinking of the
product and of security and the data on
the network okay performance we take
very seriously in persistent disk and
today we are proud to announce
substantial performance increases for
our pd SSD product for iOS we increasing
from 25,000 to 30,000 tie-ups on rice
and forty thousand readers and
throughput increases are even more
substantial we go from two hundred forty
megabytes per second to 400 megabytes
per second right and 800 megabyte per
second Reese also today we are
announcing full duplex on SSD throughput
what does it mean it means that you can
achieve 400 megabytes a second tease and
800 megabyte per second right at the
same time this is not true for I hope so
I object you can do either one or
another limit but for throughput duplex
throughput is important for many
enterprise applications and we asked
many times to provide this feature so
it's really exciting
today now i want to mention that when we
talk about a job it's important to
understand that persistent disk is a
networking disk which is really cool for
availability because you can take one
too distant this categorization
mentioned attach it to any vm and you
can shut down the vm you can keep
youjizz then attach them later it also
brings high availability of the
persistent disk but it comes with some
cost and the cost is a little bit of
extra latency our latencies are
competitive on the market but we need to
understand that to get to the high hopes
limit your your clothes should maintain
certain pew depth especially for this
ultra high hopes load the new increases
they come for large vm so for VMS up to
15 course we keep the old limits but
from 16 cores and up the limits i
increased and the maximum limits can be
achieved on 32 and higher vm digital
portion high resistant disk standard
this point characteristics are not
changed but i just would like to mention
a game that we offer very competitive
price for performance ratio for PG
standard disk and currently it can go to
15,000 try two jobs and up to 3,000
videos and throughput is hundred 20
megabytes per second on rides and
hundred h on it so a little bitter about
how we approach performance for us the
simplicity is very important in approach
to both cues and performance we want to
offer consistent performance so you pay
certain price for size you get a yoke
you get throughput with this size and
you
consistent performance in every zone
where the Easton disc is offered you
don't need to bother with striking as
Grayson mentioned and in pledges the
disc to get the best performance you can
just attach one large disk if its use
your clothes or another choice is you
can attach many small disc and you can
attach them to the same BM and you get
the same performance as large discs we
know that some other solutions they
require striping which is very it's not
it's not very a good solution for the
customers so we are happy that we offer
a simplicity here the disk size we want
you to have the disk size choose footer
for months and for space and then if you
need to get more performance we have
online ad size for you and aquas wait
performance is something that we take
very seriously in PG and we are always
looking for the feedback I'm sure we
have customers in the room and we would
like to learn more about the Austin
areas if you think we need to deliver
more ayaats more throughput if if you
think our model is too simple we would
like to talk ok well snap shot and so
one of the big requirements we hear from
enterprises or most our customers is so
what happens in the event of a failure
or what if I want multiple copies of my
data how how do you do that what what do
you have available for us first thing we
have is a snapshot and think of this
this is very similar to what most of you
are familiar with a non pram storage
array snapshots are exist independence
of the source and what I mean by that is
that oh snap shots will exist in a
different Mozilla in region then your
actual than the actual primary
let me just pause for a second about the
construct of as though in the region gcp
is actually set up in its broken down
into you have your geo areas nested
inside of the geo areas you have your
different regions and then inside of the
region you have your zone similar to
other cloud products I don't think
anyone has really filed a patent on how
they structure but overall structure
keyring of the network for snapshots as
I mentioned earlier for persistent disk
you have your vm and the data associated
with the vm is sitting in a zone and
here i talked about zone ages to make it
simple enzoani and the vm and the discs
are all sitting in region a the tot what
it's trying to show here is that you
have a snapshot and that snapshot is
actually living elsewhere in a different
region than your primary data key thing
here in the kiosk that we get from
customers as well what happens if zone a
disappears and you know we've all been
around for a while and zone is likely to
just poof and disappear but what if
there's a failure in that zone what if
you know I lose that data will I also
lose Mike the copy of that data and the
answer is no wonder most circumstances
he shouldn't because it's quite unlikely
that you're gonna have a fail that'll
affect both region a and a region
somewhere else in the country what is he
thinks about snapshots is today right
now snapshot it's totally it's a feature
that's available as part of persistent
disk but the control is totally within
the customer so the frequency well first
and foremost if you'd like to snapshot
your data that's something that we let
really doctor customers and not all
customers choose to snapshot their data
so that's let me just start with that
and then the next thing is the frequency
of snapshotting is also something that's
up to customers the technology right now
is not intended to be used as an
alternative to synchronous replication
so you know the idea of you know
snapshotting every minute or every
couple of minutes system wasn't built
for that and what will happen quite
frankly is that you'll see that your
snap
take a very long time to complete
however but what we do see and you know
what's more you know you know where the
assistants were optimized for is
snapshots daily snapshots every couple
of hours every during a day those are
the typical use cases that we see for
snapshots and and they're primarily what
people are using is first to have a
backup copy there have a second or third
copy of a given data set another big
question we often get about is where are
my snapshots thought and I know those
some people is you know why does it
matter and I know for customers so the
big thing here is coming back to this
question of is it in the event of a
failure does it is have the same risk is
the primary active data but some
customers just want to know that
regionally there's some geopolitical
issues at play for some customers and so
the the answer here is just it's stored
in GCS right now we do not make any of
the GCS api's available for light for
the objects and so the only access that
customers have to these snapshots as the
persistent disk but you know if their
customers that are interested in that
level of functionality please ping me
after because I would love to better
understand that use case and what are
the key things about snapshots and how
they're used is this idea of you can
restore snapshot anywhere and so quite
often what we see customers doing in
just earlier today we had a customer
who's using persistent desk and in
region a excuse me and they now would
like to start a fire for different
database instance using the same data
set in you know they're in the Midwest
and they'd like they have an office and
the west coast and they'd like to use
that same data set and so one of the
great use cases for snapshots is you
take a snapshot of the data set you
would create an instance in that second
zone create your persistent disk in that
second zone and at the same time then
copy the data from your snapshot over to
that
second location and that's one way of
getting access to that same data set in
multiple locations we have the other use
case here is a temporal one where you
have persistent disk and you got all
your data you're using it this week in
its status that you only use once a
month rather than pay for the disk and
keep it live all the time they'll take a
snapshot of the data Park it and a month
from now they create another instance
remount the snapshot and use the data
again so it's just another way of having
access to your data in a more temporal
fashion than having it melted all the
time one of the key things about the
snapshots is this idea that its cost
efficient this becomes relevant because
our customers are very accomplice into
the side of these you know you're
keeping copies of your data how much
data are you keeping a lot of it is
repetitive data and so do you really
need to keep many many copies of the
same data so our snapshots are cost
efficient in the sense of we do both
full and incremental snapshots generally
the first time that you take a snapshot
we will do a snapshot of the entire disk
and that's considered a full snapshot
for future snapshots we will take
differentials and so only the blocks
that have changed will be kept on a
long-term basis there are times in the
future so it's not just wonderful and
incremental indefinitely we do
periodically do full also and so there
but the key point is it's not if you
choose to snapshot on a daily basis
we're not doing full snapshots every day
some of the best practices for
performance and snapshots so we think
it's a good practice to separate data
logs and the boot disks it makes it
easier for you to manage backups and
restores don't worry if your boot disk
is small you know some customers they
tell us they create big disk for boot
and for data because we biggest have
better performance we optimized even
small disk for good good performance so
the strident we mentioned sighs in
frustration performance resize the queue
depth we also recommended some if it is
possible to adjust your workload to have
a more localized access you will get
somewhat better performance from
persistent disk for snapshots you can
take snapshots without stopping your
workload I think it's really cool
feature and it actually has no effect on
on the workload so you can keep right
into the disk take snapshots at the same
time as a matter of fact take multiple
snapshots but you have to understand
that your your your application should
be able to distort data at the point
where you take snapshot most databases
and file systems they they can but it's
something to be aware of test restore
operations as we like to say good
engineers the cup and also Mangini
assist or so back up your data restore
periodically in different zones to make
sure everything works about the schedule
of snapshot schedule first of all making
snap shots every second maybe it's
possible but it's not something we
recommend half an hour every half an
hour every one hour is is acceptable
maybe every day we have customers who
custom scripts
there Pelini's try not to schedule
snapshot a curation snapshots or
business hours or weekdays and the
importance of snapshots because we do
snapshots incremental is your next
snapshots will be fast it can be most
naps actually done within minutes you
can make it even faster and reduce costs
if you use dream if it's not enabled
because we do not have some data which
is not which is not on the disk okay um
j/ki discriminator container engine I
think the key point here I am NOT a JK
expert salam e stata the key point here
is that for cuva Nettie's actually uses
Georgie key actually uses persistent
disk as the storage for the containers
so when you create a container benetti's
cluster the storage or persistent
volumes that are made available so the
cluster are all persistent disk running
onto the cover well it's working with
the GTA team they wanted me to mention
this here and if there's any questions
or interest in this there as I mentioned
earlier there's other sessions or I
think this folks here they can answer
any of those questions
[Music]
you
[Music]